[Music]
new york state governor andrew cuomo
tried to convince young people to get
vaccinated by
saying this there is an
attitude that they'll be fine why should
they take the vaccine
maybe you go home and kiss your
grandmother and wind up killing your
grandmother
i did nothing wrong and uh period
and i'm not resigning wow i remember
that having to listen to that every day
but did anyone in the media report on
those comments
from the same man in the middle of the
nursing home scandal that cost so many
seniors their lives
how about 13 to 15 000 elderly lives
nobody did here to react is fox news
contributor and media opinion columnist
for the hill joe koncha hey joe
good morning everybody how are you doing
morning what's your reaction knowing
that he's in the middle of this
investigation in this scandal
yet he's saying that about kissing your
grandmother
yeah hutzpah right it's the only word
that comes to mind how many grandparents
did andrew cuomo kill when he decided to
put covet positive patience
back into nursing homes even a
ten-year-old knows that you don't do
that in that situation
when he had the uss comfort when he had
the javits center that the trump
administration
had given him and he decided to go ahead
with the nursing homes and then worse
was the cover-up that his own aides have
admitted to
was done in order to get a book deal
across the finish line a book deal
that made andrew cuomo very rich but
most of the media
ainsley has moved on they're quite
apathetic it reminds me of governor
ralph northam
in virginia where everybody thought he
was toast and he just put his head down
and let the news cycle
take everything out to sea and then
suddenly there was nothing to see here
anymore and the fact that
it was covered 0.0 seconds by all those
news organizations
shows that they're serving at the
pleasure of the democratic party and
believe me if this was ron desantis the
governor of florida that happened to
have an r next to his name
you would be hearing about this non-stop
so here we have andrew cuomo still
blaming donald trump for his problems
which is quite ironic when you consider
that it's a democratic attorney general
in tish james that's running one of the
two investigations
into the nursing home scandal right now
but here's the bad news if you're
rooting against andrew cuomo
sienna poll shows that 57 percent of new
york democrats
believe that he is doing a good job that
tells him
he could run again for re-election and
he could win possibly a fourth term
but lee zeldin is going to pose a very
formidable challenge that's for sure but
right now he
should be in much worse shape but the
media protecting him has buoyed his
numbers a little bit and that is just
pathetic guys
not just media but uh social media as
well you know later today we're going to
find out whether or not
donald trump is allowed back on facebook
that's going to come out later on today
but yesterday
the former president launched a new
website it's
from the desk of donald trump and
essentially what he's able to do is he's
able to put out
statements video comments things like
that
but unlike social media there won't be a
lot of interaction
what do you think about this way how the
former president is kind of
end going around the social media
companies to get
the word out it's a start
right it's it's a souped-up blog you
could call it i guess
um it's a way to get his message out to
your point uh and obviously
go through the or go around anyway the
filter of the media but i think
he has to bring it up to another level
quite frankly guys i'd like to see the
president
launch probably a podcast which would be
a very good way
uh for him to talk about items of the
day particularly
the biden administration in their moves
in terms of unraveling everything that
he had accomplished
during his four years hearing the voice
of the president would be better i know
there's a video element to this but
i think a podcast would really serve the
president well here but that facebook
announcement
this morning yeah go ahead brian i just
saying if they podcast would they cover
it would apple put it up would spotify
be able to carry it would
uh you know itunes be able to carry it
most likely no right and and that's
we're gonna hear from facebook i would
imagine this morning
that the ban will continue because
facebook just like
many in the media serve at the pleasure
of the democratic party
and look when you say well how could
facebook get away with this well they're
a private business
and the bottom line is that their bottom
line is very good facebook stock is up
100 points if you look at may 5th 2020
compared to now that's more than a 50
percent jump and before anybody says
well they got to be broken up
well who's going to do that exactly you
have a democratic house a democratic
senate
and a biden administration that is
gratefully indebted to facebook for all
the help they gave them during the
campaign as did twitter
so we're not going to see too much
action as far as breaking up these
companies or section 230
being at least amended or removed at
this point because there's no incentive
to do so
okay thanks so much joe